[Music]
before we get started notice we have
several video and still photographers so
relax and just movement
that's so great what they do that it's
worth every penny why does the duck have
feathers why to cover up his butt quack
for you two dead hookers wash up on the
hey why don't you jump in my car so
Grant Park Kirk enjoyed pop pops comedy
on the way up and white get Brad I want
to talk to you I'll see ya the girl talk
you want to be the one that she confides
in it's called the friend zone but
you'll be sad ultimately knowing that
she's not with you and eventually you'll
be invited to their wedding and their
dads like Brad what are you doing here
Teresa never talks about you and you're
like I'm invited and he's like I wonder
about that wait no no no
who is paying for that monstrosity was
Dusty's idea to cut down the tree yeah
and it was your idea to cut down the
cell phone tower crap and who crushed my
car the snowblower you did Brad crushed
my car was a motorcycle oh you again
well there's the makeup Coco did you
make tea tea in bed no it's cocoa did
your cocoa make you tea tea in bed how
would I pay upwards
how this little bit Christmas my perfect
little girl hey Roger look
yes we're all stuck here we're with our
loved ones rumbles outside the manger
it's got an arm come on bring it up
[Music]
Brad where's my dad dad don't move
there's a pack of wolves on you I kinda
wanna pet him dad don't make eye contact
with the alpha wolf
I already did right in the eyes
[Music]